"THE FIVE."
YOU GO WHAT YOU DO ALL THE TIME?
ENDED I SAY -- WHAT I SAID WAS
WHAT WILL CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR
IS THE REST OF THE WORLD
REACTING.
I'M NOT CONFIDENT OF ANYTHING,
I'M JUST STATING THE FACTS.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT BIDEN
GETTING A LITTLE TESTY WITH THE
PRESS AFTER HIS MEETING WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN, THE HIGH STAKES
SUMMIT WRAPPING UP A LITTLE
EARLIER THAN PREDICTED.
HE PREDICTABLY DENIED ANY
INVOLVEMENT IN THE ATTACKS THAT
HIT KEY AMERICAN INFRASTRUCTURE
AND CLAIMED THAT THE
UNITED STATES IS THE BIGGEST
CYBERBULLY IN THE WORLD.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID HE GAVE
VLADIMIR PUTIN A LIST OF TARGETS
THAT ARE OFF-LIMITS.
>> I TALKED ABOUT THE
PROPOSITION IN CERTAIN CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SHOULD BE
OFF-LIMITS TO ATTACK, PERIOD.
I GAVE THEM A LIST, IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN, I DON'T HAVE IT IN
FRONT OF ME, 16 SPECIFIC
ENTITIES.
I POINTED OUT TO HIM, WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CYBER CAPABILITY AND
HE KNOWS IT.
HE DOESN'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT IT
IS BUT IT IS SIGNIFICANT AND IF,
IN FACT, THEY VIOLATE THESE
BASIC NORMS WE WILL RESPOND.
THERE WERE NO THREATS, JUST A
SIMPLE ASSERTION MADE AND NO "IF
YOU DO THAT, WE WILL DO THIS"
WITH ANYTHING I SAID.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT BIDEN
TAKING A LOT OF CRITICISM FOR
HOLDING SEPARATE NEWS
CONFERENCES AND GIVING PUTIN A
SOLO PLATFORM WHERE HE WAS ABLE
TO ATTACK THE UNITED STATES.
>> IN AMERICAN CITIES EVERY DAY
PEOPLE ARE KILLED.
THAT INCLUDES THE LEADERS OF
VARIOUS ORGANIZATIONS, YOU DON'T
HAVE TIME TO SAY A WORD AND
SOMEONE IS KILLED IN AN ENTIRE
MOVEMENT DEVELOPS, KNOWN AS
BLACK LIVES MATTER.
I'M NOT GOING TO COMMENT ON THAT
BUT HERE'S WHAT I DO WANT TO
SAY, WHAT WE SAW WAS DISORDER
DESTRUCTION, VIOLATIONS OF THE
LAW, ET CETERA.
>> Dana: BY TOMORROW THIS
SUMMIT WILL BE BEHIND US, WHAT'S
YOUR TAKE ON EVERYTHING HERE?
>> Jesse: THE WAY I SAW IT,
THE RUSSIANS HACK I SEND BIDEN
INVITE PUTIN TO A SUMMIT AND
GIVES HIM A LIST OF THINGS HE'S
NOT ALLOWED TO HACK?
NO CONSEQUENCES, NO DEAL,
NOTHING CONCRETE.
HE SAID SOME CRIMINALS IN RUSSIA
DID IT, WE WILL SEE IF HE CAN
STOP IT, CALLS IT A CONSTRUCTIVE
SUMMIT.
THE REPORTER SAYS, WHAT MAKES
YOU THINK VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
GOING TO STOP DOING THIS?
AND JOE BIDEN SAYS "BECAUSE
VLADIMIR CARES ABOUT WORLD
OPINION AND HE WOULDN'T WANT TO
HURT HIS POPULARITY AND THE REST
OF THE WORLD."
I'M THINKING TO MYSELF THAT'S
ACTUALLY BIDEN, BIDEN CARES
ABOUT WHAT THE RUSSIANS THINK
ABOUT US, THE CHINESE THINK
ABOUT IT AND THE EUROPEANS THINK
SO HE IS NOT AMERICA FIRST
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T WANT TO BE
THE BAD GUY EVEN IF BEING THE
BAD GUY IS GOOD FOR AMERICA, HE
WANTS TO BE LOVED MORE THAN
RESPECTED AND THAT'S THE KEY TO
THE BIDEN DOCTRINE.
THEN THE REPORTER SAYS, DID YOU
ASK FOR HELP ABOUT GETTING TO
THE BOTTOM OF THE CHINA VIRUS?
AND BIDEN SAYS NO, I DIDN'T
REALLY DO THAT.
AND AGAIN, CHINA IS REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT WORLD OPINION
AND THEIR IMAGE IN THE WORLD IS
REALLY TAKING A BEATING, LIKE
CHINA IS GOING TO SAY IT CAME
FROM THE LAB JUST TO BOOST THEIR
POPULARITY.
HE DOESN'T GET IT, NEXT
REPORTER, MR. PRESIDENT, YOU ARE
SAYING THE HACKS CAME FROM
INSIDE RUSSIA BUT VLAD IS SAYING
NO THEY DIDN'T SO HOW IS THIS A
CONSTRUCTIVE CONVERSATION?
HE SNAPS AT THE REPORTER, LOSES
HIS COOL AND AT THIS POINT HE
KNOWS HE SCREWS UP, NO
DISCIPLINE AND HE HAS TO GO
CLEAN IT UP ON THE TARMAC BEFORE
HE GETS BACK ON THE JET.
>> Dana: HERE IS THE TARMAC
SEEN RIGHT AFTER THE PRESS
CONFERENCE, HERE YOU GO.
>> LOOK, TO BE A GOOD REPORTER
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A NEGATIVE
VIEW, I SEE THE WAY YOU ALL --
YOU NEVER ASK THE QUESTION.
>> Dana: ALL PRESIDENTS GET
MAD.
>> Jesse: HE KNEW IT DIDN'T GO
WELL, HE HAD TO TAKE SOME MORE
QUESTIONS AND END ENDS UP TRYING
TO CONVINCE THE PRESS THAT
SOMETHING CAME OUT OF THE
PSALMISTS WHEN NOTHING CAME OUT
OF THE SUMMIT AND IT LOOKS TO ME
THAT EVEN THE REPORTERS NOW
KNOW, BIDEN IS JUST ABOUT TALK
FOR THE SAKE OF TALK, IT'S NOT
ABOUT ACTION.
>> Dana: I HAVEN'T GOT IT ALL
THE WAY THROUGH, I WILL GIVE
MYSELF PERMISSION NOW, I'VE
NEVER BEEN TO MARRIAGE
COUNSELING BUT I IMAGINE THE
FIRST MEETING OF MARRIAGE
COUNSELING BETWEEN REALLY
CONTENTIOUS PARTNERS WOULD BE
LIKE THIS WHERE THEY AFTERWARDS
HAVE TO COME OUT AND HAVE A
SEPARATE PHONE CALL.
CANNOT BE SEEN TOGETHER.
>> Greg: TO JESSE'S POINT, THE
MOST BIZARRE PART OF THIS WHOLE
THING WAS WHEN HE SAID, HERE'S
THE LIST OF AMERICAN ENTITIES
THAT ARE OFF LIMITS WHICH
SUGGESTS, YOU MEAN THERE ARE
ENTITIES THAT ARE ON LIMITS?
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT'S THAT LIST?
THE FIRST ONE IS FOX NEWS.
IF YOU GO AFTER MY DEAR CNN, I
THINK THEY DID, RATINGS HAVE
DROPPED 76%.
HERE'S THE TAKE HOME.
PUTIN GOT A PIPELINE AND WE GOT
CAPTAIN CRANKY PANTS.
NOT ONLY DID PUTIN HAVE THE
ENERGY, HE WENT HOME TO THE
ENERGY.
HE WAS LIKE A TEENAGER YELLING
"I DID MY HOMEWORK" TO THE
PARENTS, MEANWHILE PUTIN IS LIKE
A RELAXED, ALERT IGUANA FASTING
ON A RIVER ROCK.
IT'S NOT ENTIRELY JOE'S,
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S FAULT.
PUTIN IS LIKE HOW THEY DESCRIBE
HIGH SCHOOL IN "DAZED AND
CONFUSED."
I GET OLDER, THEY SAY THE SAME
AGE.
EVERY SEMESTER AMERICA HAS TO
REPEAT THE SAME CLASS, RIGHT?
HE GETS A NEW GUY EVERY 4-8
YEARS SO THERE IS A NO REAL
INCENTIVE FOR HIM TO DEVELOP A
LONG RELATIONSHIP AND IT'S THE
SAME WITH CHINA AS WELL SO THEY
KEEP CHANGING, HE, LIKE THE
GIRLS IN HIGH SCHOOL KEEPS
STAYING THE SAME.
>> Dana: PETER DOOCY WAS ABLE
TO YELL AT HER QUESTION AND IT
GOT ANSWERED.
HIS FINALLY ABLE TO CONNECT THE
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM, RUSSIA AND
CHINA ARE GETTING CLOSER
TOGETHER AND THERE ARE FINANCIAL
RELATIONSHIPS THERE AS WELL AS
OTHER COOPERATIONS.
>> Harold: I HAVE A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT TAKE ON THE SUMMIT.
I THINK IT WAS TWO ADULTS WHO
DON'T LIKE OR TRUST ONE ANOTHER,
I THINK IT WAS OUR PRESIDENT
MAKING CLEAR TO HIM, I FOUND IT
A LITTLE ODD SAYING THESE ARE
OFF LIMITS IN THE SECOND
QUESTION, BASICALLY SAID TO HIM,
YOU'RE GOING TO SAY YOU DIDN'T
DO IT.
HOW THEY REACTED TO THAT
MEETING.
I THOUGHT HE RESET THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA, LAID
OUT VERY CLEARLY, WE ARE TWO
ADULTS AND HERE'S WHAT YOU CAN
EXPECT FROM ME GOING FORWARD AND
WHAT YOU CAN EXPECT FROM THE
UNITED STATES RATE I DON'T
NECESSARILY AGREE WITH ALL THE
THINGS YOU SAID BUT I UNDERSTAND
SOME OF THE FRUSTRATIONS WITH
HOW THIS MIGHT HAVE GONE AND WE
ARE LOOKING FOR BIG
DELIVERABLES.
THE BIG DELIVERABLE FOR ME WAS
THE G7 AND NATO REUNITED US
THERE, PUTIN, SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE WORLD HERE.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE THE
FREE REIGN YOU HAD OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS, YOU'VE GONE
THROUGH FIVE PRESIDENTS, YOU MAY
GO THROUGH TO CALL MORE ABOUT
YOUR BIG CHALLENGES THAT YOU
WANT TO BE RELEVANT AND YOU ARE
NO LONGER RELEVANT, WE ARE GOING
TO ORGANIZE OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY STRATEGY OVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS AROUND HOW TO BEAT
CHINA IN A NEW COLD WAR.
YOU ARE OLD NEWS, BAD NEWS AND
IF YOU DO MORE WE WILL
RETALIATE, THAT'S WHAT I HEARD.
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK WE ARE
SPEAKING THE SAME LANGUAGE, I
DON'T THINK PUTIN HAS HAD FREE
REIGN FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS, HE
GOT A PIPELINE AND A SUMMIT AND
THERE WERE NO CONSEQUENCES FOR
THE HACKS.
>> Dana: WE WILL SEE WHAT THE
DELIVERABLES ARE, THE SUMMIT IS
ONE THING THAT THE FOLLOW
THROUGH, WHERE DO WE GO FROM
HERE?
>> Dagen: I'M WAITING TO SEE
HOW MANY OF THESE 16 TARGETS GET
HACKED.
HE BASICALLY TOLD
VLADIMIR PUTIN, HERE ARE OUR
MOST VALUABLE ASSETS.
HAVE AT IT.
NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, I DIDN'T QUITE LIKE
BIDEN'S HOLIER-THAN-THOU STANCE
ON HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES GIVEN THE
FACT THAT HIS SECRETARY OF STATE
PUNTED BIGLY, WHEN HE MET WITH
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY BACK
IN MARCH.
RUSSIA IS A JV TEAM COMPARED TO
CHINA SO IF BIDEN WINS AND EVER
MEETS XI JINPING HE NEEDS TO
STEP UP AND NOT LET MURDEROUS
TYRANTS TELL US WHAT'S RIGHT AND
WRONG AND SAY HEY, 2 MILLION
PEOPLE IN CONCENTRATION CAMPS
AND GO THROUGH THE LIST PAID I
DID LIKE, THERE'S A DECENT STAGE
CRAFT GOING ON WITH BIDEN TODAY,
"THE SUN IS GETTING HOT" AND HE
DOFFED HIS SUIT COAT AND FOLDED
AND THEN HE'S GOT HIS AVIATORS
AT THE READY, IT CREATED THAT
MOMENT OF, LIKE, GRANDPA STILL
KNOWS HOW TO DRIVE A STICK.
>> Dana: I TELL YOU, IN TERMS
OF STAGECRAFT, THE ADVANCE WORK
BY THE AMERICANS VERSUS THE
RUSSIANS WAS MUCH BETTER IN
TERMS OF THE BACKDROP FOR THE
PRESS CONFERENCE VERY WELL DONE.
>> Greg: IS GOING TO BE
SOMETHING, WHEN TRUMP EVER SAID
SOMETHING THAT WAS DIRECTIONALLY
TRUE I MAY BE FALSE OR WHATEVER,
HE BE FACT-CHECKED AND NO ONE IS
GOING TO FACT-CHECK
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
WHEN JOE SAID THAT THE PEOPLE
WHO BREACHED THE CAPITAL KILLED
AN OFFICER I WAS UNDER THE
IMPRESSION THAT THAT'S NOT THE
CASE AND THAT A POLICE OFFICER
ACTUALLY KILLED AN UNARMED
FEMALE PROTESTER, THAT WASN'T
MENTIONED.
WHEN HE SAID THE PEOPLE THAT
REACH THE CAPITAL KILLED AN
OFFICER I THINK HE WAS BEING
HARDER ON TRUMP THEN HE WOU